et qu'elle doit bouger rapidement pour rattraper.
Pour réfléchir au progrès possible,
j'aimerais vous inviter à faire un exercice d'imagination.
Imaginons que nous puissions remonter 100 ans en arrière,
disons aux États-Unis, en 1917,
mais que nous puissions apporter avec nous toutes les idées modernes,
les innovations et les inventions dont nous disposons aujourd'hui.
Que pourrions-nous accomplir avec tout ce savoir ?
Jusqu'où pourrait-on améliorer la qualité et les conditions de vie des gens ?
Jusqu'où pourrait-on répandre la prospérité ?
Imaginez si, il y a 100 ans,
le système d'éducation avait le savoir dont on dispose aujourd'hui,
y compris les meilleures méthodes d'enseignement.
Les docteurs et scientifiques en sauraient autant que nous
sur les mesures de santé publique, les techniques de chirurgie,
le séquençage de l'ADN, la recherche et le traitement du cancer ?
Et si on avait aussi accès aux semi-conducteurs modernes,
aux ordinateurs, aux appareils mobiles, à l'internet ?
Imaginez !
Si tel avait été le cas, nous aurions fait un saut prodigieux vers l'avant, non ?
Eh bien, l'Afrique peut faire un saut d'une telle ampleur aujourd'hui.
Il y a suffisamment d'innovations non exploitées
pour faire bondir l'Afrique 100 ans en avant en termes de conditions de vie,
si la volonté et l'engagement sont au rendez-vous.
Ce n'est pas qu'une possibilité, mais bien un impératif pour le futur de l'Afrique,
un avenir qui verra la population de l'Afrique doubler
pour atteindre 2,5 milliards en seulement 30 ans ;
un avenir qui verra l'Afrique abriter la plus importante main d'œuvre au monde,
alors que l'idée même du travail est redéfinie de manière radicale.
Faire ce saut vers l'avant n'est pas une idée si farfelue.
Il y a des tonnes d'exemples qui démontrent le potentiel
qu'a l'Afrique pour le changement.
Il y a 20 ans à peine,
le Nigeria avait moins de 500 000 lignes de téléphone en opération.
Aujourd'hui, il y a 100 millions d'abonnements cellulaires,
et ce miracle du mobile est imité par chacun des pays de l'Afrique.
De nos jours, il y a plus de 750 millions de cellulaires en service en Afrique,
ce qui stimule un engouement justifié pour un progrès accéléré,
pour l'implantation d'une économie de partage, de l'intelligence artificielle
et de la machinerie autonome en Afrique.
Tout cela est très prometteur,
mais nous devons penser au séquençage.
On ne parle plus de mettre la charrue devant les bœufs,
mais de ne pas mettre la voiture autonome avant les routes.
(Applaudissements)
Il y a tout un pan infrastructurel et logique de l'innovation
que nous prenons pour acquis,
mais en Afrique, on doit faire le tri,
car certains des manques les plus flagrants de nos infrastructures
sont des choses si basiques,
que les Occidentaux ont rarement à y songer.
Jetons-y un coup d'œil.
Imaginez que votre connexion Internet ne fonctionne plus pendant une journée,
et quand elle recommence à fonctionner,
elle n'est en service que pendant trois heures,
avec des interruptions aléatoires de 15 heures chacune ?
Comment votre vie serait-elle affectée ?
Maintenant, remplacez l'accès Internet par l'électricité.
Songez à vos frigos, télévisions, micro-ondes,
hors fonction pendant des jours.
Maintenant, imaginez que ce cauchemar s'applique aux bureaux du gouvernement,
aux entreprises, aux écoles,
aux hôpitaux.
Ce scénario, et parfois pire,
est le type d'accès qu'ont des centaines de millions d'Africains :
l'accès à l'électricité,
et à l'eau courante,
et à la santé,
et aux services d'hygiène,
et à l'éducation.
On doit changer cela.
On doit changer cela, car s'assurer d'un accès large et abordable
à des services et des infrastructures décents
n'est pas seulement un objectif simple ;
c'est fondamental, en vue de faire ce bond de 100 ans.
Quand nous aurons solutionné cela,
nous profiterons peut-être d'avantages inattendus.
L'un des avantages inattendus du miracle du mobile
a été une résurgence culturelle, sans doute la plus spectaculaire
que l'Afrique ait vécue en une génération :
la renaissance de la musique populaire africaine.
Pour des musiciens comme P-Square,
Bongo Maffin
et Wizkid,
les téléphones mobiles ont tracé la voie vers une domination locale
et une gloire mondiale.
Cet impact ne se limite pas à la musique ;
il touche aussi le cinéma.
Des films magnifiques, engageants,
comme nous le démontrent ces images de « Pumzi »,
« Vaya » et « I Am Not A Witch ».
Même si l'image qu'elle projette vers l'extérieur semble dépassée,
l'Afrique continue d'évoluer, tout comme le cinéma africain le fait.
Maintenant, il arrive de temps en temps que le reste du monde s'en aperçoive,
peut-être avec le film coup de poing « Viva Riva ! » de Djo Munga,
ou avec l'intense film « Ezra » de Newton Aduaka,
ou avec le poétique film « Timbuktu » de Abderrahmane Sissako.
Avec leur cellulaire, les Africains découvrent de plus en plus de ces films,
ce qui veut dire qu'à Kinshasa ou à Cotonou,
ce que le Festival de Cannes pense d'un film africain importe bien peu,
tout comme importe peu que ces opinions soient documentées ou justes.
Qui se soucie vraiment de l'opinion du « New York Times » ?
Ce qui compte, c'est que des Africains valident cet art et ces idées,
tant de manière critique que commerciale,
qu'ils regardent les films qu'ils veulent,
et que les cinéastes africains soient en contact avec leur public de base.
C'est ça, l'important.
C'est important, parce que le cinéma peut illuminer et inspirer.
Il peut nous amener, ici et maintenant, des visions de l'avenir.
Les films peuvent être la courroie de transmission de l'espoir.
Le cinéma peut changer les perspectives plus rapidement qu'on construit une route.
En un peu plus d'une décennie seulement,
l'industrie du cinéma au Nigeria, la plus importante d'Afrique,
a permis de porter les mots et les langues de notre pays
vers le vocabulaire et l'imaginaire de millions de gens
dans de nombreux autres pays d'Afrique.
Il a fait tomber les frontières,
peut-être de la manière la plus efficace depuis la Conférence de Berlin
qui a semé les divisions linguistiques et géographiques à travers l'Afrique.
Le cinéma parle un langage universel,
et croyez-moi, le cinéma nigérian parle fort !
Pour que l'Afrique fasse ce bond de 100 ans,
les Africains devront faire appel à la créativité pour générer des idées,
et devront s'ouvrir pour accepter et s'adapter aux idées venant d'ailleurs
pour résoudre nos problèmes récurrents.
En mettant l'accent sur l'investissement,
les films peuvent être un moteur de changement pour les Africains.
Un changement qui est nécessaire pour faire ce bond de 100 ans ;
un changement qui nous aidera à créer une Afrique prospère,
une Afrique radicalement meilleure que celle d'aujourd'hui.
Merci.
[En Swahili] Merci beaucoup.
(Applaudissements)